all around is destruction
so the mission for search teams here is
a mammoth one
we're with russian specialists the first
international rescuers to reach the
blast
epicenter
the tragedy which shocked the world is
being viewed up close by
foreign eyes for the first time
they will carry out this search for as
long as it takes
the chances of finding anyone alive at
this late stage are very slim but
they're not prepared to give up just yet
this is where thousands of tons of
ammonium nitrate was hidden away in
unsafe conditions for more than six
years
the task ahead will be difficult and
often dangerous for this team
but there's already reason to hope we
have a map from an engineer
and we know that there are five meters
for the floors under the ground down
there from from the
ground floor or from the basement from
the ground and the basement
the underground chamber could still be
intact and would have offered some
protection for any workers there
and they are praying for a miracle do
you think
seeing the level of destruction here
that anybody could still be alive
only if and if they were under the if
they was under the ground
there's a small chance yes if they are
anywhere any place above the ground no
there's no chance because other than the
explosion there is too much smoke and
chemicals
so if they survive they will suffocate
[Music]
this is a long job and it takes patience
and the rescuers know
time is not their friend
on the other side most of the grain
silos were ripped apart by the blast
they've made a discovery but the grim
faces say it all only pieces of body
one tells us it is a desperately bleak
assignment for these lebanese soldiers
and tough on the volunteer civil defense
who are helping them
there is growing alarm and anger here
and demands to know how the explosion
was allowed to happen
[Music]
in the city's hospitals where many are
still veering between life and death
and coping with horrendous injuries the
anger is most raw
as long as the the the rulers
of lebanon are saying the same nobody
can help us
ila suffered multiple injuries whilst
driving when the explosion happened
i'm very extremely lucky to be alive
actually
because i ca i can't i can't forget the
explosion the sound
the the visuals in front of my eyes wow
and i literally saw body parts of people
thrown in the main road people screaming
kids screaming body parts i saw a hand i
saw two legs
that doesn't sound like something you're
going to be able to recover from very
quickly
uh i won't be able to recover actually
if i stay in lebanon i'm not going to
stay in lebanon at all
anymore
seven-year-old alexander was playing in
his front room when he got hit
such as the randomness of this tragedy
his mother nearby
was unhurt she's now wishing she could
take his place
and her fury is tangible i don't know i
don't want to think about it
and i don't care i really don't care
i just want to leave this is what i want
i just want to leave everyone stay in a
place where
there's no politics there's there's no
guns there's
no religion
this is what i really think
we cannot live like like this cannot
leave this one more time
it's too much to handle it is really too
much
so many in lebanon are like this now and
crying out for change
alex crawford sky news beirut
you